top gun fans the day is finally here top
gun maverick has officially landed in
theaters but the action isn't only in
the sky no it is on dry land as well
with tom and his big-screen muse
jennifer connelly
moment on the back of the bike i mean
that is an iconic moment for the
franchise it was really fun not
something that comes up in my everyday
life riding on a motorcycle with tom
cruise jen when she committed to penny
was very exciting for for all of us
because she's so talented
and
lovely penny uh benjamin my character is
mentioned in the original top gun movie
he told me all about the time you went
fullistic with penny benjamin we know
that they've clearly been in and out of
each other's lives all these years yeah
we know it's a movie about flying but
we're also here for the romance tom even
added an extra scene for it originally i
wasn't supposed to fly in the movie
because my character is not an aviator
so i was actually in the plane with
him shooting a c that was just supposed
to be on the tarmac with him at first
scene very impressive maverick's back to
train a new group of elite fighter
pilots and just like in the movie tom
put his cast through their paces in real
life teaching them to fly and survive
the dunker you're strapped to a chair
you're blindfolded and then they slowly
start submerging you in water
you take you take a final breath and
then it starts to flip you upside down
and then you have to get out anybody
have to tap out i mean tarzan didn't
know how to swim i was afraid of flying
glenn was just born a badass
do you remember like the first time you
launched off one of these things
they tell you to keep your arms like
this because like you're gonna go flying
forward i decide that i wanna
i wanna take a video of the whole moment
my phone
goes flying explodes yeah just a
slingshot everyone was looking at you
being like are you really going to try
and everyone's like
[Laughter]
it's like
one of the best experiences i've ever
had making anything because of that
infectious
enthusiasm that tom has for making
movies he's one of the last true movie
stars with a capital m and a capital s
[Music]